hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to SCP containment
breach okay
markiplier whoa I'm gonna make a new
youtube channel called markiplier pwned
it's gonna be all Call of Duty a metal
or metal of duty
Medal of Honor stars could be called
Duty all day long alright let's try to
with that what that oh no oh no what the
hell
I hear myself what happened I ha ha why
is it black why is blackness hang on try
that again I hope it didn't destroy my
save that was a good save
ah ah no no no no run forward don't fall
haha fudge I gotta start a new game
no I'm never gonna find everything if
that happens markiplier
Zod master up all right how about this
aah xxx mark Capone X X X 3 360 up X X X
3 yeah oh
start a new game but I'm getting better
at this so hopefully I'll be able to go
farther that's what she did okay here we
go oh it's so bright and nice ah flaws
are that okay shut up mark
wah poon X X X 4 coz zero one two and
three were taken is that it
this is a bad blazer I'm just
embarrassing myself there's a bad part
back oh alright actually X Marcoux boom
x5 of all the other ones were taken
do not intro
oh good I'm delaying the inevitable
I'm trying to offset the terror I will
experience with humor okay well good oh
there we go the whole emergency
situation is hotter nephron breaches
okay extender good fit though give me a
good chance I can get by this guy can do
this I knew this I'm heated way to go
tiny boat oh hey move move where did he
move where did he go
Wow Wow
where did he go okay all right let's
just go maybe you left not fair not fair
it's not fair not fair not matter where
the hell is he no near is iam okay I
can't looking right in the door where
are you
Oh screws screw this I'm just going to
bugger out and hope he respawned oh go
away go go oh my baby doctor again okay
here we go again
here we go where are you yes maybe
through a room it's all this then
okay okay okay okay
battery what's that okay cuz I can take
this off now Oh God
alright I've already got that that's too
many dad Oh what's with the endless
repeating always oh I know this
first-first going on here tell this ha
looks promising promising ah it's right
in here
what's going on what is this I'm gonna
close that door always close your voice
is bright in here it's all that about
okay all right I'm a bit confused
come on oh not this again
well yeah I saw the other one let me let
me pull it off and going that way for
just a hot second
good there's definitely areas that I
have not seen ah ah hey moment just get
whatever there and get it go oh hi hi
how do you get to oh I see not fair it's
not fair it's not fair
okay there's something and then that I
need get it go what down I got it what
was it but no I didn't get it oh boy
get it something I need
and get it I didn't get anything you
still in there get out of here Oh lag
why lags
why oh boy there's something in here
that lagging oh no going on what's going
on my soul lag oh oh come on ah I don't
know why I suddenly started leg let me
kill myself here there we go
let's open now I do that freed it up a
bit
once again this game is very indie it's
bound to have a lot of bugs I see it
just crashed okay hell is assuming that
it was um gonna do memory access
violations so let's just get right back
in the action here and go here comes the
fraps now know what now sorry
here it is accessed mine and that's my
xbox name too pretty badass I know when
people see that they know I mean serious
business okay framerate drop
ha ha ha visit project you got ah I got
your number funny I know your tricks
ah Wow
how can you do that ah get it fudge
oh honey I don't know what happened when
I went in that room I wasn't looking cuz
I am turned around where am I
I know you're there
really what do i do what do I do
do I do
hi okay can't get Randy all right I'm
not even gonna try that where am I
oh wait no I know where I am oh god damn
it what was happening there I don't even
know we forget it forget it forget it
together go in here and close the damn
door damn it what the balls is there
another one right there I don't even
know I don't even know like my eyes
suddenly Sh like my eye meter goes to
nothing
figure something out here
save doesn't seem to be okay seems sweet
so far was it black here whoa okay okay
okay okay
ah office thank you good my business
card in here
Oh making some bacon did you get there
you ever you mother-effer grab
everything grab everything
oh I got it okay hunky-dory ah chasing
me oh so close I close it close it close
it close it close it in buzz it oh it's
like I can hear it scraping what's this
what's this
why no no no no he's everywhere it's
frickin everywhere
oh he's everywhere and nowhere and
no it's not not happy fun time okay not
going in there what's it already open
was it a this is an elevator don't why
is it black eyes a black ones if it's
black I can't see can't see anything
there's nothing oh it's nothing it's
just a wall a bad idea this is a bad
idea this is a bad idea that's bad is it
black again what's going on going on oh
no don't tell me like this elevator is a
freaking SCP it's all black this is
black this is black oh no it's just a
solid wall
oh no I failed again uh-huh
oh there's nothing here
this is probably this elevator spine SCP
that makes you trapped in here forever
or something stupid like that
yep I'm boned I'm not officially okay I
don't know I don't know either down but
I'm all out of time oh so many things in
this game that I just every time i load
up a new game that's like something new
so oh man so anyway thank you all so
much for watching and as always we'll
see you in the next part
bye bye